Escribí este poema después de escuchar a una actriz muy famosa
decirle a un entrevistador muy reconocido en televisión:
"Últimamente estoy haciendo mis pinitos en internet.
Ojalá estuviera más organizada".
Entonces --
(Risas)
Si yo controlara internet,
podrías subastar tu corazón roto en eBay,
tomar el dinero, entrar en Amazon,
comprar una guía telefónica de un país en el que nunca has estado y llamar a gente al azar
hasta que encuentres a alguien a quien se le de bien coquetear en una lengua extranjera.
(Risas)
Si yo controlara internet,
podrías buscar en Mapquest los cambios de humor de tu amante.
Girar a la izquierda en malhumorada, a la derecha en preocupada,
dar media vuelta ante un silencio incómodo,
seguir todo derecho hasta encontrar un beso con lengua y un buen amor,
y podrías navegar y entender cada intersección emocional.
Algunos días, soy tan superficial como un molde para hornear,
pero aún así me extiendo millas en todas las direcciones.
Si internet fuera mío, Napster, Monster y Friendster.com
podrían ser un único y gran sitio.
Así podrías escuchar buena música
mientras haces que buscas un empleo
y en realidad, estás charlando con los amigos.
(Risas)
¡Cielos! si yo controlara la web, podrías enviar correos electrónicos a los difuntos.
Ellos no podrían responderte --
(Risas)
pero tendrías respuestas automáticas.
Total, su nombre en tu buzón de entrada --
(Risas)
eso es todo lo que querías de ellos.
Y un mensaje diciendo, "Hola, soy yo. Te extraño.
(Risas)
Escucha, ya verás, estar muerto es genial.
Por ahora, ve a criar niños, pedir la paz y desear caramelos".
Si yo diseñara internet, infancia.com sería un ciclo
de un niño en un huerto, con un bastón de ski como espada,
la tapa de un bote como escudo, gritando, "Soy el emperador de las naranjas.
Soy el emperador de las naranjas. Soy el emperador de las naranjas."
¡Ahora síganme! ¿Vale?
(Risas)
Abuelita.com sería una receta para galletas e instrucciones para un baño relajado.
Uno, dos, tres.
Eso te enlazaría con perritobiohúmedo.com
Ese sería mi abuelo.
Que te llevaría a ex-policía-gruñon-casado-cuatro-veces.papá
que sería un archivo adjunto a
excéntrica-que-manda-galletas-de-gengibre-para-navidad.mamá
y que descargó al niño del jardín, al emperador de las naranjas,
quien creció para convertirse en mí --
ese tipo que normalmente va muy lejos.
Así que si yo fuera el emperador de internet,
supongo que aún así sería mortal, ¿no?
Pero para ese momento, probablemente tendría
la hipoteca más baja posible
y el pene más largo posible --
(Risas)
así que prohibiría el spam desde mi primer día de trabajo.
Ya no lo necesitaría más.
Sería un tipo de genio de internet, y yo,
me mejoraría para ser algún tipo de deidad y entonces, como si nada --
pop - Me haría inalámbrico.
(Risas)
¿Eh? Tal vez Google podría contratarme.
Podría comprimirme entre tus servidores y firewalls como si fuera un virus
hasta que la World Wide Web sea tan sabia, salvaje y organizada
como creo que un milagro/oráculo moderno puede serlo, pero, ooh-eee,
¿quieres apostar como despertar y "des-PC-ear"
lo que tu Mac o PC serán cuando yo sea el mandamás,
El dios gran cosa.net?
Supongo que es como la vida misma.
No se trata de si puedes.
Simplemente lo es, ¿sabes?
Podemos interferir con la interfase.
Podría hacer "Lo tienes, Aleluya" el himno nacional del ciberespacio.
cantarlo cada vez que nos conectamos.
No dirías una oración.
No escribirías un salmo.
No cantarías un mantra "Om".
Sólo enviarías un correo electrónico bendito dirigido a quien creas que debe recibirlo